yeah welcome to this video playing are
reeling from our Aryan or something from
Iceland and we cut them the triangle the
triangle is a particular sub variation
of the Queens gambit where c6 andy sixx
are combined it is similar to the same
it's laughs but so oh he set the setup
of the as it's um I got a comment from
an earlier game against the vampire I'm
not sure about the upload order and he
said this is um he lent this from the
game more rows of its against
Tomashevsky so probably probably this
wasn't so bad then at least it was a
label alright so but this referred to an
earlier game that I played um here black
played somewhat strange movie official
b7 just giving me the center in fact
this move order was DC for Knight f6 um
yeah this is quite interesting um it's
playable um but it's tricky ok so now
I'll threatening me 45 winning the h7
poem
so it's a quite strange setup for black
fibers the strong threat he needs to go
h6 probably okay
so if i just take you five what is the
in the big point is not getting it back
if i go h okay if i go h3 he's got night
if no he does get queen 85 should before
know what's not working ok so just
castles non-threatening h3 so we
probably has to go 97 ago if I just let
that just first protected not spend ages
here it's a problem good for white in
various ways d 5 and then I know then if
f-4s hanging
night to d2 mhm
I try their various ideas to exploit the
somewhat loose position of this night
only five once it has taken here
hmm
okay yeah i already spent too much time
on this
okay night b3 is going to c7 and this is
probably not so bad the night assaults
are not well placed on b3 in general but
of course he threatens to take on d3
zone I need to to do something about
that
yeah I don't like the night that but put
them know what else I'm not playing so I
need to have it protected maybe one idea
was after the bishop moves to go F for
so having an additional porn in the
center the e4 pawn but I didn't really
refuel e5 which is most certainly
complete nonsense
yeah white is still comfortable here but
it's not not a refutation by any means
I'm slightly more comfortable due to the
extra born in the scent and the better
this is a strange one white wave might
Bishop d7 or deck this is strange we had
just threatened to to take now and g4s
just hang
hmm maybe I should have spent a couple
of seconds at least if there was a
complete win because again this is not a
win here it's just good for white and it
looked like there should be a win okay
now it's a it's a very very nice
position but so you cannot call it a win
now the pawn will go go to these seven
immediately if it takes
I just means them you shouldn't exchange
yeah this is also not not a big problem
you can we can take them ft 7
immediately
probably here this is good controlling
the important squares maybe yeah i just
noticed that this Bishop is hanging ah
just notice that rookie for this is a
threat here unbelievable
yeah the analysis after this game will
really hurt this is something that's
completely clear because I probably
missed like five wins or something it's
still good for white because all this
completely freezes up his position
time boarding check check
the checkmate yet Queenie too I think I
know it's quiz on a sec mwah ha ha why
should we take a break it out yet
Queenie to ya then then this is winning
this is really winning made made this
imminent here again we can give one or
two checks but it's not what the heck I
really overlooked so much in this game
yeah this really keeps everything nicely
together this is ok but here it starts
to get get mochi of course I can also
just retreat the rook but giving it up
as says to get the pawn it's not a bad
idea what I overlooked is that in this
position this this pin it's just this is
hanging I cannot move v7 and this is why
I needed to play something else first
and then it's not entirely clear but
what he needs to do badly is get this
rook to e1 like taking check something
like that so this ruckus is active and
d7 group d 8 blocks the pond so he still
doesn't have a dead rook on on evade and
in the game after a couple of muscle
here we had this position where he can
leak and he cannot move force pieces and
this already is very very tricky for
black maybe a computer can can do
something to hold it but he quickly fell
apart maybe it was isn't in halfway
decent a decent play now it seems like
that so I only really made one one big
mistake to give them exchange under that
circumstances well wear this pin was was
the problem
and I want what I'd like to check is
here here this this position looks
completely sick for like because this is
everything's tied together so there is
something yeah in fact the computer says
that this is the best way to play it
looks it looks very tricky to me like
there was something better but this is
of course an overwhelming position I
only overlooked this this pin motif
alright thanks for watching